okay as always our recordings of our
virtual meetups will be available on
youtube about a week after the meetup
and we'll post a message on meetup when
the recording is ready
okay i am very pleased to introduce our
speaker today alexander smith alexander
smith is a fifth year graduate student
working in the lab of victor zavala
prior to pursuing his phd he worked for
five years as a senior engineer in both
manufacturing and r d at eli lilly and
company
alex's research focuses on the
development of topological and
geometrical data analysis methods for
applications in various engineering and
scientific domains
so alex is comfortable if you just want
to ask questions throughout the talk or
ask in the chat
you can do it there and i'll interrupt
and speak your question um or you're
very welcome to meet yourselves um and
ask yourself
um so take it away alex
all right great
thank you for the introduction
um let me share my screen here oh wait
um
i need to share my entire screen
there we go okay
i hope everybody can see
the full screen now okay
yeah so uh as before i'm alex smith i'm
in the group of victors of all at
uw-madison in the department of chemical
and biological engineering
and today i'm going to be focusing on
something known as the euler
characteristic
which we're really going to use as a
general topological descriptor
for complex data
and so the way that i kind of want to
frame this talk is by looking at you
know the reasons why we're leveraging
these methods
through various chemical engineering
applications right so
the first application that we're going
to be looking into are these ideas of
liquid crystal sensors so for those of
you who may be unfamiliar liquid
crystals essentially
uh represent a state of matter that has
characteristics of both liquids and
solids right so this might be something
that flows like a liquid but has long
range ordering like a solid these are
used in tvs and things like that
but what's also nice about liquid
crystals
is that we can make uh
very accurate sensors with them
and so what we're looking at here
is sort of a visualization of how these
sensors work and so what we're doing is
we're taking a thin film of liquid
crystal
and depositing it on a reactive surface
and so basically at the beginning of the
simulation you can see the lego crystals
are sort of homeotropically bound to
that surface so they're kind of standing
on their heads
and they're interacting with these
binding sites on the surface
now what's nice is that we can tune
these binding sites to be reactive to
particular analytes right so we want to
detect so2 carbon dioxide carbon
monoxide etc
and so what happens is that gaseous
analyte that we're seeing in yellow when
we expose the sensor to it we'll diffuse
through that liquid crystal and actually
bind to those surface sites
now when that happens it interrupts the
interactions between the liquid crystal
and the surface and they start to
reorient right and when that happens we
get these really interesting optical
responses in the sensor
so here are actual images of
experimental setups that we have for
these sensors right and so
on the left hand side right is where the
sensors start out right so these are
where the liquid crystals are
homeotrophically bound to the surface
and what we're seeing is we're looking
at this through a cross-polarized
microscope
and so light is polarized passes through
these sensors and then it hits a second
orthogonal polarizer and so when it hits
that second polarizer if that light
hasn't been refracted or bent in any way
then we're just going to see a black box
right now when we expose this sensor to
a gaseous analyte right we start to see
changes in that system these liquid
crystals reorient and they actually bend
and refract that light
around that polarizer and we start to
see patterns form
so here we're seeing is the beginning
over time and then eventually we get to
the end point where we get these really
interesting sort of patterns and
textures that start to show up in our
system
now you know these sensors are really
great at detecting the presence of an
analytic but we also want to understand
the relative concentration of that
analyte right so you would have a low
concentration where it's non-toxic
versus here where maybe somebody needs
treatment after exposure
right
and so our goal here is to quantify the
topological differences between these
endpoints of the sensor responses
so
uh you know again here what we're
looking at right
is the data set that we're going to be
looking at so on the left hand side we
have a set of sensors that have been
exposed to a low maybe non-toxic analyte
concentration
and on the right a set of sensors that
have been exposed to a high analyte
concentration and so this is just a
subset there's a much larger data set
here i'm just showing you a few samples
from this data set
but again our goal right is to quantify
the differences
between these sense responses using
topology
so the first question is right how do we
measure the topology of an image
right and so what we can do
is we can actually take our images right
and basically represent them as
manifolds
right and on that manifold we can have
some function that represents in this
case the pixel intensity right so here's
one way to visualize it and then here's
more of the manifold structure that
we're going to see right so we still
have our x and y spatial dimensions but
now we have a third dimension right that
sort of corresponds to this function
mapping
right and but if we look at this image
right from a topological perspective
there isn't anything really interesting
going on right because it's just a
single connected component there's no
like holes or anything in it right
so the question is how do we take this
and get meaningful topological
information out of it
so one of the ways that we can do that
is through something known as a
filtration
right and so on the left hand side i'm
kind of illustrating
uh what's happening during this
filtration right and so what we're going
to do is we're going to take that
function that's on our manifold and
we're just going to threshold it right
so we can imagine this sort of plane on
the bottom here
basically going from the bottom of this
image all the way to the top
right
and as we pass that plane up through our
through our system here we're going to
slice off more and more of that manifold
and everything that's below that
threshold is going to get in added into
the shape that we're measuring
and so
we're doing that at each point in this
threshold and what we're going to do is
measure the changes in the topology of
that corresponding shape as we perform
that filtration
right so the way that we're going to
measure quantify topology in this case
is through something known as the euler
characteristic
and what we're doing here right the
euler characteristic is simply you know
simply put is the number of connected
components minus the number of holes
in the image or the manifold
and so here what i'm showing you is what
we're constructing from that system
which is called the euler characteristic
curve so at each point in this
filtration at each of these threshold
levels we're going to compute the
topology of that corresponding image
and so here we have our initial
filtration piece right so if i threshold
this system at point two you can see the
threshold goes up a little bit and
basically what we're finding right are
these formation of connected components
in our system
and so this starts to drive our euler
characteristic more positive
now
the connection here right is that these
connected components are really
capturing the local mac or minima of our
process right so we're sort of picking
up the local minima of this function
on this manifold
as we keep passing through right we pick
up more and more of these local minima
we end up with more and more connected
components and that drives our euler
characteristic value more positive
now as we keep going through this
filtration right we're going to pass
something else that's interesting which
are saddle points in our system
right so we pass these saddle points and
what happens is these individual
connected components start to join
together
right and eventually we get to the point
where we're at like a single connected
component but now we see that there are
many holes
forming in this system
and what's interesting is that these
holes represent the presence of local
maxima
in our function
right so we go from connected components
very positive to a single connected
component with many holes which drives
us negative
and eventually
we get to the point where we have a
single connected component right we're
back to our original image which is kind
of sort of topologically trivial it's
just a single connected component
but the important takeaway here right is
that i've taken this complex
two-dimensional image
and i've converted it into this simple
one-dimensional function
right and we can really think of this
euler characteristic basically as a
vector of values that describe this
image so sort of like a feature vector
for this image
so now that we've gone through that
process right we can apply that to all
of the images in our database
and we can start to see differences in
these two groups right so here we're
looking at is the average order
characteristic
for our low concentration samples
versus our high concentration samples
and what we see right away is that there
are definite differences
in these two groups right we can see the
low concentration system looks very
different
and
again our goal right is to separate
these sensor responses via this euler
characteristic curve
right and so what we found
right was that we're able to actually
classify this data set
with 95 accuracy using a simple linear
classifier
and previously to get this same level of
accuracy we required complex
convolutional neural networks
right so the euler characteristic is
able to simplify the data representation
but also simplify the models needed to
get optimal performance
okay and so one of the things i
want to show is that you know this is
not some trivial result right we are
actually doing something that's
meaningful here and so
what i want to compare is the euler
characteristic curve method to another
very common method which is the 2d
fourier transform of images
right and so what we're doing here on
the left hand side is basically taking
our curves which we treat as vectors
right stacking into a big matrix
performing pca
on the right hand side we're doing the
same thing with the 2d fourier transform
stacking into a big vector matrix pca
and what we find on the left hand side
right is that when we look at the euler
characteristic curves we're seeing that
there's a great separation in the data
just using the first principal component
really
for this system
and when we look at the fourier
transform right the data is very much
overlapped
right so what this foreshadows is that
when we try to do the same sort of
linear classification on the right hand
side
we end up with a very poor result
so euler characteristic really is
capturing information that something
like the fourier transform is missing
and so here i wanted to show a quick
example of this and all the examples
that i'm going to show are all contained
in this github so
some of them have examples some don't
but all of the code for all of these
examples is found in here
and so i just wanted to quickly go
through and show you kind of how this
code works and basically point out the
main package that we're using in this
which is called gudi
and so gowdy is basically you know we're
given an image it can compute the
topology for us
right
and so here what i'm using you know i'm
importing gudi just a few analysis tools
nothing really spectacular um
just doing some formatting
and here what i'm doing in this block is
basically
creating a function
that passes through our image filters it
right through our filtration and then
we're using goodie to sort of compute
the topology at each point in that
filtration
right
and so here i've defined that function
i'm defining the filtration in this case
and for this example right i'm not
allowed to share the actual lc data so
what i did was i generated another data
set that's basically from random fields
uh but those are known to well match
these lc sensor responses
right so here i'm creating a method to
create those data sets
we go through the data set right create
the ec or the characteristic curve the
fourier transform etc
here are some images of the two
different environments we've generated
right so we have environment one
and environment two and if we look at
them right there are some differences
but it would be really difficult to
really tell these two apart
so again we go through we perform our
euler characteristic transform on these
systems get our two curves our average
curves we see that there's a difference
and here i'm just going to perform pca
and we see that these two environments
are basically perfectly separable
in this case
and then if we go down here right we
look at the 2d fourier transform in this
system and we find that there's really
no separation
so
um
you know that's just a single example of
that analysis now
what's really nice about topology in
general right is that it generalizes to
higher dimensions right i can do the
same type of analysis with a higher
dimensional object without worrying
about really changing how the
mathematics works in this case
right so previously right we had our llc
images with our manifold representation
and now i want to go into a system where
we're looking at molecular simulations
and now we're looking at things in three
dimensions
right
and so here we're looking at our
molecular simulations for the conversion
of biomass basically into usable
products right so polymers
and things like that
and what's interesting or a hypothesis
behind these studies
is that you know here we have our
reactant which we're trying to transform
and basically if you dissolve that in a
particular co-solvent water mixture it
can actually change the efficiency of
that reaction
right and so one of the hypotheses
behind that is that the water structure
in our simulations is actually driving
that change right so the water structure
around the molecule will actually get
shifted around and will change how
efficient that reaction is
and so the way we want to study that is
basically by looking at these molecular
simulations which are pretty much just a
bunch of molecules bouncing around and
sort of chemically interacting with each
other
and we're going to create a water
density manifold which is basically
looking at the entire simulation space
and then averaging the positions of
water over time in that space
so here again we have our water density
manifold right and again what we want to
do is sort of quantify the topology
of the system
and so you know previously what we
looked at was sort of a two-dimensional
manifold with a function
on it so now what we're looking at is a
three-dimensional manifold with a
function associated with it so
previously i could illustrate you know
it has a 2d plane passing through the
system so this would have to be a 3d
plane passing through a four-dimensional
system and i have no idea how to draw
that if you have ideas please let me
know
um but basically
what we're looking at here right is that
same exact thing right we're going to do
that filtration where we set some
threshold and then we increase that
threshold
and while i can't illustrate the exact
filtration to you i can kind of show you
the level sets that we were looking at
previously
right so just like we were doing with
the previous simulation
or the previous data set
and so here we're seeing right as we
pass through we're getting these low
density areas which kind of show up as
different connected components
in our system
as we keep increasing that threshold we
start to form holes or handles as they
might be called in this case right so
that's where we're getting this sort of
negative value here
and then eventually we get to the point
where we get a third feature right and
these didn't exist in the
two-dimensional systems but can exist in
three-dimensional systems
and these are what are called voids
right and so basically it's like a hole
or an air pocket right that's been
entrapped in that system so it's
completely encapsulated inside that
surface of that manifold
and so that's where we start to see this
second peak is because of the presence
of voids in that
system but again right what we're doing
here is we're we're taking this really
complex three-dimensional manifold with
a function and basically summarizing it
as this simple vector of values
and so our goal right is to take this
information
and understand these simulations right
and so another interesting piece about
these simulations and about topology in
general
right is that it's invariant to a lot of
different types of deformations of the
data so in this case right if we look at
these density fields which we've
sub-sampled from the same simulation
right so here we have different parts of
the simulation
if we look at these density fields
and you looked at them and you tried to
say okay it's hard to tell
that these are all you know
from the same simulation right they all
look very different
but if we measure their topology through
the euler characteristic
right we can see that the euler
characteristic for each one of these is
almost identical
right so while this density field is
changing over time
the topology of it remains very stable
and so that's important especially if
you're going to sub sample simulations
for training a particular model right we
don't want to get a different answer at
one point in the simulation versus
another point from the same simulation
now okay so here what we've done right
is we've taken these water density
fields
and we've converted them all into these
euler characteristic curves
right and so chemists and chemical
engineers are very interested in saying
okay can i go from this simulation in
this topology and predict an
experimentally verified reactivity right
so that i can instead of going into the
lab and creating these systems can i
just do it via simulation right
and so what we're doing here is we have
for each one of our other characteristic
curves
right for each one of our simulations we
actually have experimental values for
the reactivity increase
right or decrease if it may be
right and so basically what we're doing
is we're training a linear model
using these euler characteristic curves
and predicting this actual physical
experimental reactivity that's been
verified in the lab
right so we train this model and then we
use this linear regression model to go
in and say okay can we predict for a
completely different set of chemistries
completely different set of co-solvents
can we predict that experimentally
verified reactivity
using this simple linear model
right and what we found right is that we
are able to do that quite well it's not
perfect but it's it's very very close
right and again what we're seeing right
is we're using the simple linear model
we're using this simple topological
representation of the data
and previously to get
this same level of accuracy
we had to train complex
three-dimensional convolutional neural
networks to get this same answer
right so again this is an example where
representing the data via topology
allows us to kind of cut down on a lot
of the nonsenses in the data and use
simpler models to get as good of results
as with 3d cnns things like that
um okay so now i want to go into a
different example
where here we're looking at you know
not images or or voxels but here we're
looking at our multivariate time series
right
so here's what we call the tennessee
eastman data set and those of you who
are unfamiliar the tennessee eastman
data set is basically
a very high fidelity simulation of a
complex chemical process
right and what people have done with
this simulation data set is you know
they've run it and they introduce
different types of faults into the
system so what they could do is they
could go in and crank down the
temperature of something uh reduce
remove a feed stream etc right
and the goal with this data set is
really to use the process data that we
get from the system to detect changes in
process behavior
so here's an example of some of the data
that we get from the system right so
here for example is a simulation of the
process in the presence of fault one
fault seven and fault fifteen
right and so what we're seeing are these
really complex multivariate time series
that we're really trying to understand
and if you look at them in the raw
format right it would be impossible to
tell
which fault belongs with which time
series
right
and so we need a better way of
representing this data
that's uh you know amenable to our
computations right
and one of the things that you know i've
noticed in my study and with some of my
collaborations is that there's actually
a really deep connection
between
process systems and this multivariate
time series analysis and an area of
neuroscience right and what's
interesting is that neuroscience has
taken this different approach where they
actually represent these multivariate
time series as topological objects
so just to give a little background on
some of the problems that i've worked on
right so here
is what we're looking at right this fmri
data where basically what we're doing is
we're taking a patient putting them into
an fmri machine
and having them read a book watch a
short film solve a math problem etc
and basically what we can monitor in
their brain at different locations are
things like blood flow temperature
oxygen content etc right and basically
after we process all this data what we
end up with is an interesting
multivariate time series very similar to
what we're getting out of our process
data
and
so in this problem that we're addressing
right here what we're looking at are
sets of patients with developed brains
and then a set of patients with
underdeveloped brains
and each of these patients has been put
in the machine and basically told to
watch a short film
and we're going to watch how their
brains react and then try to distinguish
between these two groups right
and so
one of the ways that we can do that very
efficiently
right is by representing this data as a
topological object
and the way that we're going to do that
is by taking our fmri data which is
again a multivariate time series
constructing something like a
correlation matrix right so it could be
correlation covariance etc
but basically what i'm doing here is i'm
looking at the absolute value of
correlation between each of the
variables
in this time series
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
treat this correlation matrix basically
as an edge weighted graph
right so basically at each point in our
brain we're going to consider that a
given variable
and then we're going to draw an edge
between each area of our brain
and what we're going to do is we're
going to weight that edge with the
absolute value of correlation between
those two variables
right so we go from this multivariate
time series to this sort of edge
weighted graph
now what's nice about edge-weighted
graphs is that they're amenable to
exactly the same thing we're doing
previously right which is filtrations
right
so instead of looking at a function on a
manifold right we're going to look at
this function on our edges of our graph
and so we're going to do is we're going
to threshold this graph
right and so here i'm going to start at
a very low threshold so i would start
off with basically if i went above this
a bunch of nodes right there are no
edges
i'm going to slowly increase that
threshold and as i do so i'm going to
add in more and more of my edges until
at the very end i end up back with my
completely dense graph
and what's really nice is that for
graphs we can compute the euler
characteristics simply as the number of
vertices minus the number of edges
right so at each point in this
filtration we can compute that
so again here's an illustration of our
filtration right and then on the right
we have our euler characteristic curves
right and so here i'm looking at the
absolute value of correlation as my
filtration
and then we're just measuring the
topology of that graph as we pass
through the
and what immediately sort of jumps out
right is that there's a definite
difference between the topology of
graphs with developed brains versus
underdeveloped brains
so we notice here immediately the
correlation matrix topology is really
able to quantify these differences and
the presence of these brain
abnormalities
now what we're going to do right is
apply that same sort of strategy to our
process systems data
right so here we have our process system
and now we can decide sort of think of
this as a brain right it's got all these
different measurements but it'll be
measuring things like temperature flow
uh level uh you know concentration et
cetera
right and we get out of that our
multivariate time series and again we
want to use the sensor data to detect
faults in this process system
so again we're going to do exactly what
we did before
right take our multivariate time series
construct our correlation matrix
and from that construct our correlation
network
right so now we have our topological
object that we can measure
and so here on the left-hand side right
we see our filtration where again we're
taking that filtration we're going up up
up we add more and more edges to our
system until we get back to our fully
dense graph
right
and what we can see right through the
euler characteristic
is that we are actually able to separate
out when the system is behaving
correctly
versus when the system is experiencing
faults so again this correlation matrix
topology quantifies these process faults
right
so here i want to show you a quick
example of how this works
uh through our python here through our
github
and this one is actually very very
simple right so i'm not really
introducing anything here i mean these
are all just simple packages
and here is really the the bones of the
code
right
all i've really done to construct my
euler characteristic right is input my
matrix which i'm calling a
and some threshold here
right
and all i'm doing is converting that
into basically a binary matrix which
becomes essentially an adjacency matrix
right and from that i can compute my
edges vertices and then my euler
characteristic
right so it's literally like three or
four lines of code and i can get that
out right
and then i can combine this with my
filtration
and okay sorry so here we're loading in
the data loading in the data
there's the correlation matrices that
we're seeing an example
and then here i can just you know
compute my euler characteristic for
these systems and again we get back
that original result
right so very very simple way to sort of
handle some of these more complex data
sets
now
um
one of the things that we notice right
or a few of the things that we notice
about this right is that
process monitoring the ec curve is nice
because it's fast computationally right
so they should be very scalable
uh we're not required to fit any sort of
model or anything like that other than
computing like correlation or covariance
it's also nice because it provides a
global descriptor for this process right
but we notice some things right so when
we look at this data set right we see
the faults are kind of grouped into two
groups but when we look into the
individual groups we're not seeing much
difference right so it's difficult to
distinguish between the actual faults
themselves
and so one of the ways that we want to
address that issue is through something
known as romanian geometry
and this is more recent work that we've
done
so
when i talk about romanian geometry i'm
specifically interested in the space of
symmetric positive definite matrices
right so
all of the matrices that we're concerned
with are going to be symmetric and
they're also going to be positive
definite in this case
right and so here we have our example
matrices and on the left i'm sort of
illustrating what those matrices might
look like
on this manifold right so this spd
manifold as i call it
is iconic manifold
and basically
any matrix that is going to be spd of
this same size is going to sit somewhere
on this cone
right
and what's interesting is that these
matrices all form this particular
romanian manifold right so it's some
manifold that's embedded in some ambient
euclidean space
now the question is why is that
important why do i care about this right
and the reason we care about it right is
because when we do a lot of data science
and machine learning one of the inherent
assumptions that we can make right is
that our data lies in some linear vector
space
right so things like euclidean distances
are absolutely true when we discuss the
relationships between these components
right so here we're looking at so let's
say here i make that assumption i look
at my matrices and i say
okay i'm just going to assume they're in
euclidean space let me compute the
relationship for the distance via the
forbinius norm between these points
right and what i find via the euclidean
distance is that x1 and x3 is actually
you know the distance between these two
is actually greater than the distance
between x1 and x2 right i could do this
do this with the frobenius node
but what's important to note right is
that euclidean distances do not reflect
the underlying manifold geometry
right we're sort of ignoring that
now
let's look at it and let's consider the
geometry of the data
right
and here what i can compute because i
have this manifold i'm aware of it i can
compute something known as a geodesic
right and this geodesic is basically
going to be a distance that's
constrained to this manifold itself
right so if i were to go any point on
this uh this path between x1 and x2
it's guaranteed to be an spd matter or
an spd matrix right
and so now if i look at these geodesic
distances right i get a different story
right now i see
x1 and x3 are actually closer
than x1 and x2 so i'm getting sort of
the opposite answer than i would if i
just assumed euclidean space
right
and
so you know we can do this via this
simple romanian metric here
and
what's important right is that you know
not only do we want to consider the
geometry of the system but we also want
to be able to implement it in our data
science tasks right like classification
regression uh dimensionality reduction
etc right so how can we take this
manifold geometry and start to integrate
it into those tasks
so the first step in that really is
identifying something known as the for
shame mean
of our data
right so here we have you know just an
example set of data points right and we
can imagine that this is some subset of
that romanian manifold right that spd
manifold
and what we want to do is we want to
identify the centroid on that space so
basically the point on that manifold
that minimizes the geodesic distance to
all other points on that manifold right
with respect to our data
the way we can solve that is through
this simple optimization framework here
this problem
and here i've computed the for shaming
for the tennessee eastman data set right
we can see that x-bar is basically an
spd manifold or an spd matrix which is
guaranteed to be and it's of the exact
same size as the other matrices
right
and so
the reason we want to compute this
central point is because we want to find
a point where we can construct a tangent
space
and basically unfold this manifold onto
this linear vector space
right so here we have is our our
centroid right and we're constructing a
tangent space at that centroid so any
curve or anything that's going to pass
through this point we can construct uh
you know we can take the derivative
and find where that tangent vector
points and then create a space from
those tangent vectors
now what we're going to do is basically
this tangent space is a vector space
it's a linear space
and so we can take this really curvy
manifold and basically squish it onto
this mount onto this tangent space and
make it completely flat
right so we can think of this as similar
to looking at a globe right of the earth
if i want to measure distance
on the globe it's going to be very
difficult for me to do it with a flat
ruler
right but what i can do is i can take
that map that globe and project it onto
a flat plane
and now i can start to measure things
like distances areas angles all sorts of
stuff
and the reason we identify the frechet
mean right is because that minimizes the
geometric distortion of that projection
right so like if you look at a map of
the earth that's been projected
right most of the time things that are
very near the equator have almost no
geometric distortion but if we look
farther out like the north and south
pole right we can see that they're very
inflated right so there's a lot of
distortion there
so picking this point allows us to
analyze our data in this linear space
with minimal distortion to the data
and so again here are points that sit on
that manifold right so here's an example
of one
and here i've projected it to the
tangent space right so you can see
it's the same type of matrix just the
values have been shifted
and so we're going to do that for each
point in our data set
and now the other important point right
is that now that we're on this tangent
space we're actually in a vector space
right so now we can perform things like
pca dimensionality reduction etc without
worrying about the curvature of that
manifold
sorry my dog is barking a little bit um
okay so
here what we can see right is basically
i'm comparing the principal component
analysis with raw data where we haven't
done this tangent space transform right
this is basically assuming that the data
kind of sits in this euclidean space
versus accounting for the geometry
of that manifold on the left hand side
and so what we see right is that when we
look at our no-fault simulations
on the right-hand side they're basically
completely overlapped
with our faulty simulations which are
shown in these different gray scale
values
if we look at the left-hand side where
we've just projected the data onto that
tangent space
we can see there's a great separation
of the no fault simulations from the
faulty ones
what we also notice right is that some
of these faulty simulations are actually
clustered into groups that we're not
seeing on the right hand side
so this suggests that we might be able
to classify these systems with a simple
classifier and separate out the actual
faults in this process
so here we have right again is our raw
data right and we're doing this
classification task right so what we've
done is we're trying to train a model
that classifies you know whether a given
fault is occurring in the system
and so we're looking at the right hand
side is what's called the confusion
matrix right so basically with the
confusion matrix an ideal one you would
see all ones in the diagram
right because what that means is that
every time i predict
something to be experiencing fault five
it's actually experiencing fault class
and that would be
true right any value on the off diagonal
right is going to represent a
misclassification
and in particular in this classification
task right we see that we're predicting
in this case false negatives
right so here we're saying there's no
fault when in fact many times there is a
fault present
right we can kind of see that where we
have this overlap
so basically the accuracy is very low
when we use the raw data
now
what we've done right all we've done is
taken our data and projected it onto
this tangent space
and we're going to do that exact same
thing right so accounting for the
geometry of this manifold
and what we see right is on the right
hand side if you look on the diagonal
we're seeing almost perfect
classification of the data
right
and when we look at faults 3 4 9 and 15
right we see poor classification but
those faults are all classified within
each other
right we're not seeing them being
classified in other spaces
right so this suggests that maybe these
matrices don't you know aren't
accounting for enough of that
information and maybe injecting more
information to this would allow us to
better separate these classes
um okay and then so i'll go through a
quick example of this here
um so here we have you know
this one's a little bit more in-depth
and i won't go through it in too much
detail but again it is available so you
can feel free to look through it and see
how it goes um basically importing a few
packages a lot of sklearn stuff just for
the classification etc
some formatting things
um here i'm just importing the data
computing the covariance matrices
here i've defined some matrix operations
that we'll need for this algorithm
the biggest piece really here is
computing the for sha mean
right so basically what we've done is
we've set up an
algorithm that basically computes a
gradient descent step
on the manifold itself
right so we can solve this problem uh on
this manifold and this problem is
geodesically convex so we can use
gradient descent and we're pretty much
guaranteed to get an answer right
and so we can see here right if we look
at our loss function versus our step
number we're getting to within a very
high tolerance
um you know within seven steps so it's a
very easy problem to solve
once you've identified that for shea
mean right we can take our data and here
all i'm doing is just projecting it onto
that manifold
or onto the tangent space and then here
i'm taking the tangent space data
performing dimensionality reduction and
we get our answer
right
and so here of course is the
classification results and we can see
again that issue with 3 4 9 and 15
uh not being as well classified
okay
and
so basically in summary
right uh what we kind of talked about
here is this idea of topological and
geometrical data analysis
right so the goal of this right is
really to take our data and represent it
um in some topological geometric way
right so we can look at things like
manifolds point clouds graphs
and then integrate the topology and
geometry of those systems into different
tasks right so like unsupervised
supervised learning et cetera
and then here are some of the
application areas where we've been able
to apply this
things like collective behaviors
space-time dynamics
process networks some of the things that
you've seen
in this talk
and so with that i'd really like to
acknowledge all my collaborators my
experimental collaborators in this case
uw madison and cornell
uh my advisor victors of all of course
and then references where um all of this
stuff that we've talked about should be
available or is available and then also
another topic called uh persistent
homology which is maybe a more advanced
area of topology applied topology uh
that might be of interest to everybody
and then of course we have our code here
which is just through github and zavalab
ml
and with that i'd like to thank you all
for your time um and i see there are
some chats that i just saw uh so
i'm not sure if there any questions but
i'd be happy to take any more questions
great thank you so much alex um
i have a couple of questions so yeah
organizer maybe i get to go first and
people can feel free to fill the chat
with questions
um so so i have two one i kind of missed
how did you go from something in
chemistry
to spds
um
oh right right so um
spd matrices is that what you're asking
yeah like
yeah okay
there's something chemistry and then you
got a matrix okay okay yes yes so i
should be more clear about that okay so
so what i'm doing here
is
i'm basically using these chords so
these correlation matrices and things
that we derived from this process data
that's basically what i'm using here
okay so i've i've computed those
covariance or correlation matrices you
know in this case covariance matrices
and i'm using that data to try and
distinguish these different types of
faults that occur
uh in this process system because the
euler characteristic was able to say you
know our process is behaving correctly
or it's incorrectly but it wasn't able
to distinguish between those different
types of faults
and so here what we're saying is okay
we can leverage the geometry of these
matrices now to sort of get a more a
clear answer and a better answer than we
were with just the straight up euler
characteristic curve
cool
uh in my second question i recognize
it's a little bit ill-defined
um but you're saying that the euler
character's characteristic is stable or
maybe i would say invariant with respect
to the water density simulation yeah um
and i was wondering is that like
something you know from chemistry or did
you need the math to figure that out
um yeah so so i use uh stability here uh
very loosely uh we don't have actual
proofs
for this uh
but basically yeah what we're doing here
is is we're looking at these
observations and you know when we look
at these density fields they're very
different so there are a lot of
deformations that are occurring from
like a geometric perspective or
something like that spatially
but we measure them topologically
they're very similar and so
one of the things that we think is
happening here is that these systems are
actually behaving like random fields
and so the structure of random fields is
very well defined from a topological
perspective and so that's why i think
we're seeing uh this stability so i
don't have a proof for it but i think
we're kind of getting to that point
where we could say something like that
more strongly
very cool
uh i'll just read some of the comments
kevin mcdonald said i thought this was
incredibly interesting gave me lots to
look more into thanks for sharing this
yeah of course yeah kevin and if you
have any uh
questions or anything you know feel free
to email me or reach out to me
i think my website is on the on the link
and i'll put my
my email in the chat as well
so
feel free to reach out
yeah i definitely will
i don't have any use cases for this now
but i definitely wish i did it seems
very very cool
yeah absolutely
yeah yeah of course
eric klisman feel free to speak
hi um the uh time series plots that you
show
uh they look very dense is that because
uh the time series is really moving like
that or these are plots of multiple time
series
uh yeah so these are so in each one of
these plots i have 52 time series right
one for each
yeah i see i see and the correlation or
covariance is uh
between these 52
yes that's absolutely right okay now i
understand i hadn't seen uh topology
applied to time series before this is
very interesting to me thanks for
presenting
yeah of course yeah and of course you
know if you have any ideas down the road
feel free to reach out uh
you know i'd be more than happy to help
out
terrific thanks dr
yeah you have a question from the chat
ted kai asks thinking about the
euler characteristic that you calculated
in your 2 and 3d examples does the fact
that your data is discrete pixels or
voxels instead of true continuous data
affect the ec calculation
uh yes so that's a very insightful
question um yeah so here what we're
looking at is something called uh
basically converting these
objects into simplicial complexes right
in this case they'd be cubical complexes
and so yeah so because we're not as
refined right it could impact the
topology of these systems slightly right
as if i had a more continuous field or i
even you know split these voxels into
even smaller voxels and took uh
an approach from there
um so yeah it can affect it and the way
you discretize it can affect it but
what's interesting right is that you
know if you look at these topological
features in their structure
right we can see that you know because
we're looking at this from a topological
perspective rather than a geometric
perspective we can still have these big
topological features that we can capture
and it might be unaffected
by how discrete we're looking at right
because all we're concerned about with
topology is really this idea of
connectivity
right
rather than actual physical size
so um so that can be one of the benefits
of looking at it through this lens but
um if you go to uh the gowdy website
right um and and you look at some of the
papers that that we have listed at the
end here uh that can give you a greater
explanation of how that works
and how it can or cannot how it might or
might not affect uh the result of the
topology
yeah it's a very good question
there was previously a couple of dms i
got just asking for
links if you're comfortable sharing your
slides um and also for the github link
yeah of course yeah um
yeah i'd be more than happy to share the
slides and then uh
the github link is all the way over here
yeah so i can put that um
see if i can put it in the in the chat
or well i guess i can't copy it but
you'll have it with the slides and
you'll have links to all the problems
and and every single one of these uh
problems that we've addressed also has
an example in the github so you can go
ahead and mess around and do whatever
you want with all these examples
great
wait a little bit to see if
any more questions come through
okay well
thank you so much um we're also getting
thank yous in the chat um this is a
really great and clear talk for such a
mathematical topic i really appreciate
it personally yeah yeah of course yeah
thank you that's a huge compliment so i
appreciate it
as a reminder this is a monthly meet up
we're generally
the fourth thursday of the month um so
keep an eye out on our meetup page for
our next meetup
good to see everyone yeah thank you all